this year he has dedicated
2020 to trying all different types of
coffee
and making more and more elaborate
lattes at home
so everyone please welcome rafi good
morning everybody
well thank you jared for the
introduction i really appreciate that
yeah i've i've been
doing a lot of lattes at home um
a it's it's actually pretty
exciting side business i'm going to
start i'm going to have to start
inside of r uh good morning everybody
um this gonna be a talk about something
that i'm really passionate about it's
actually was the same topic of the first
dcr meetup is how do you take solution
from r not just a it's not a statistical
analysis but a solution for clients
and what we've done around um really
serving it as a solution for
client out in in in the real world
um so a little bit about myself real
quick
um again i'm an elite data scientist for
deloitte
i run r for governments at the
deloitte gps um and i do a lot of work
around
a different agencies a little bit of
commercial
um really focusing on the advanced
analytics part over there
again using r in particular um
and before i start i just want to say
thank you for two individuals who are
building on their work
and plumber and docker um i think
you know if you have opportunity really
look at how what they write about
and and the work that they're doing um a
lot of what you're going to see over
here really stemmed from there
so um this talk is really not going to
be about
um i'm not going to show a whole lot of
code
um it's really about a how i had a
problem
and how do we went about solutioning
that uh using the tools that are
available to all of you
without needing for a huge
infrastructure it's not a docker
training it's not an aws training
it's the little that you know to make
this thing work and then you can go from
there and stock overflow etc
um so again um i am going to focus on
four
aspects of a solution how i deliver r at
capacity
to production to an entire state
um and we're going to start with the
left side of the equation of the r model
itself for recommendation we'll touch a
little bit about that
in in the plumber how do you actually
serve that how we
containerize that and really able to
serve that as a as a whole
and then um using microservices
essentially how do i use
aws capabilities which are allowing us
to take this r model and really serve it
at scale without the need to know a
whole lot of cloud work
um and finally how do we communicate
that out to the public
um and again this is a real solution you
guys can hit it right now
and i'll show you in a second how um
so a little bit of a background and this
is a text heavy slide and i'm not trying
to
i know it's a deloitte's feature but the
solution that we have built
under an umbrella called govconnect is
really how states and local governments
are really communicating to
citizens um the solution specifically
over here in kentucky
is called is a resource engine and
what this is provide is
an access to citizens to know what
services are available to them in the
community a
food bank which is very very important
right now uh education
um clothes and child care and the like
so this is an entire this is a website
that you can go into
um and really search for based on your
location
and if we know something about you
because of eligibility system
and what we know what the state know
about you we can start giving you
access to resources that might be
benefiting to you
specifically the work that we have done
in and the our work is really related
to the personal intelligence which is
the items
users like you like amazon users like
you who looked at a
also looked at b or users like you who
looked at a
also considered b or will benefit from c
the reason this is really important is
because we know that most people don't
actually
know what's available to them not
everybody is
google savvy um it's really important
that
we really enable people to either
self-sufficiency
enable people and nudging them in the
right direction but more importantly
it's the community helping the community
everybody like you will help you get to
where you need to be
and that's kind of why this kind of
capability is really important
what it's actually looks like is like
that when the user gets to a resource
they have some information that they can
see around
uh for example skills um
and at the bottom you can see frequently
paired together
and related services and what you can
see over here and related services are
similar
similar it's the same thing just maybe
in a different location
um and the frequently paired that's the
complementary that's where the
recommendation come into place
and that's really where you start
getting
other services that you may not know
about that you can actually
get access to and again all this is live
and in production
now the uniqueness of this situation
um of of this is it's not like netflix
it's not like
amazon the reason that it's not is that
because we don't have one to five rating
nor do we have anybody buying anything
or
purchasing anything or or anything like
that
uh the goal is really for individuals to
become aware to actually know that this
exists
um that's that's essentially a success
now we don't actually get rating we know
if you connected to something but we
don't actually get
rating because only if you come back and
say yeah that partner not the service
but the partner was a vet was good
then we get some feedback back now it's
also
binary um and implicit so
it's is um it is essentially
um it is essentially
the the yes or no did i
connect or not and finally again we only
care about relevancy
now let's go into the nitty gritty of
this solution
so what we have over here is again we
have the our capability around the code
to get the data the modeling and we'll
touch on that in a second the delivery
is feeding into plumber all of this is
dockerized
sitting on a farragut infrastructure
which is a serverless
serving of of of this docker
and it can scale up and that's how we
can serve an entire
state um and then behind api
gateway so we have security so the
system
my r code and the model and the data is
actually secure
and only get through the api gateway
so we will i will walk through each one
of those items in
this specific r component that matter
all in all the solution we also have the
ability to reproduce
um in other location so
i'm going to talk about recommendation
system but it can be applied to any
model that use
a api gate api and the like
so deep dive into the recommendation
first um the first aspect that i
i want you to think about is that we
essentially segmenting the population
think
clustering um and by the way segment is
not all pregnant woman
it's essentially um people who will
behave similarly
um and it's essentially i'm first
boiling it down from the entire
infrastructure
we have the uh the metrics that we
created and again you can see it's a
function of the information that we get
we created a metrics and then using this
wonderful library recommender lab i'm
creating an item-based collaborative
filtering so i
encourage all of you to go and google
what item-based collaborative filtering
but think about this as a metrics
where i have the items or the the
individuals that actually
are selecting that and and the items
that
all the resources food bank and the like
that they actually selected
as you can imagine this is a this is a
really really really spurs metrics
um so we have to handle that but
the recommender functionality will
create that
uh real metric metrics that then create
this outcome which is essentially the
base for the model
now the second part how do i actually
make this okay
you build a model how do i actually do
something with that
so the second part over here is that i
create the plumber functionality so
in three seconds or less um i'm
creating and you can see at the top
right over here
i'm creating the post functionality of
plumber
so that means that it's not through the
url i can actually
serve a body and you can see in a second
why i need to serve a body
but this is information such as the user
id the where they are
and what they're looking at um
and what i'm passing in variety what i'm
passing to this re
based model so this is my exam for the
base of purpose of this demo
um this is the base model that i'm
serving
and you can see on the right over here
that i'm i am getting a function
i'm getting the user the variable that i
need i'm
creating i'm using my function get
writing
ranking distance matter for example
um how far you are from the resource
that i'm trying to recommend
um and i'm essentially the outcome of
this function is a response out which is
essentially a list
uh this is important because again in
the api i'm serving a json file
we'll get there in a second but this is
important i'm serving a list
now um in in the next piece is actually
the critical and this is the if you
remember anything from this talk is the
next piece
i'm serving the model i'm creating the
the plumber router that's through the
new pr uh functionality um
a few months ago a new plumber a
library was released um it's a it's
wonderful i encourage all of you to take
a look uh but what's important over here
is now
i am using the pr run um
to start a server i'm using a host
0.0.0.0
on port 5001 now this is really critical
how do i serve this um
there is a port is essentially will
that's the port where
the where we're listening on but why do
i need the host.0.0
the key over here and this is really key
how to serve this in production
is that by default docker has its own
namespace the namespace is essentially
its own
infrastructure ip and the like um if i
want to connect the docker to a
different environment
i need essentially to forward the port
from the 5001 the port that i'm
that i'm actually opening in the ip that
the docker
provide and you can see on the right the
bridge i need to essentially listen to
all of them uh so to achieve this i need
to listen
on an external ip inside the inside the
container
and that's here is all ipv4 so it's
listen to everything
that will allow me to have the
connection from the docker
to the external environment now once you
do that
now you can create the docker and this
is where it's a
it's a very um again you can
this will be posted this is the classic
a
docker for for r uh i'm using the
the base rocker environment are we
updating the linux i'm creating a copy
that's copy everything from my directory
all the code all the data
in all the functionality that i need in
order to serve that
i'm running the script set up and that's
all the install library x install
library y
um and then i open the 5001 which we
discussed
in a second ago and then the entry point
is a container start it serve this sme
base
sr a base s1 um
that's my um i'm not very good at naming
i'm the first one to
to admit that um and that's where it's
going to start so it's going to start
this server
that essentially starts the plumber on
five zero zero one
which then uh showed the re based
functionality that we saw over here arya
based model
now comes the fun part um is the aws
infrastructure
i took this docker dockerize that i put
it on ecr
and that's the services from amazon to
where docker can live
at a very high level now and again this
is not a training on aws but i'm going
to tell you essentially what we found
was the right way to set this up um
and a lot of it i'm you can use the
wizard of aws
you use fairgets for clustering and
we'll touch on this in a second
behind application load balancer behind
api gateway
and there's some cloud watch for a logs
so faregate gives me the essentially the
services that would scale up
using the application load balancer uh
the method is
how api gateway check is the post
is it gets uh is it part of the url the
package
an api gateway is essentially how aws
manage the connection to the external uh
services um that is where the api will
actually live
so in the next two minutes i'm really
going to talk about these components
and you know while you you you well you
can read and learn about how to do this
and
how actually to deploy that where is the
plumber and the r comes into place
so the first thing that you need to do
is to create that cluster
so if you go to ecr and you create
cluster
the first thing that you need to create
is the task
and what's important in the task um
is that you need to link to the
container you need to say which
container you're actually using
and very important over here is that
when you open the container when you
link to the container it will ask you
you know what report you're listening to
so the classic port 80 is you know
opened
or port 20. those are the classic one
that kind of internal communication
no use the 5001 that we open in the
plumber
it's because that's how plumber is
essentially sending out
from the docker container out to the
to the environment the recommendation
the second part over here is that now
you need to go and create an application
load balancer
um you go through the wizard you can see
configure load balancer configure
security and the like but really
important again when you confirm to
when you get to the routing that's the
target what it's
essentially targeting um again you can
see ip
port five zero zero one again you will
see that there's a
there's a a path over here
from this from the plumber that opened
my
function on 5001 through the task
through the load balancer the next step
is looking at the service so you go back
to the
to the clustering and now you set up a
service
um and you select the service it will
ask you what you want to do
regular or fare get choose faregate the
reason faregate i should have mentioned
that
is fergut is essentially their
serverless they will manage for you
how much you grow in in in
compute power um so the more you hit it
the more docker container will be spun
out
um i should mention that uh this is
actually really really
really fast um with the new rocker so
this is
actually thank you um so you create the
service and again
uh you select your virtual private cloud
etc but again
what's really really important is that
when you create the service
when you get to the security group
essentially what
ips can go in and out you
look at your port for the application
load balancer you're using the
application load balancer
um is a group id um
and the port range again is 5001.
finally we get to the application the
api gateway and
and this is a nifty trick that i want to
i'm actually i learned and i think this
will be very interesting to everybody
is that when you set this up instead of
a post or
get you set it up as a proxy and then
in the endpoint url you use the stage
variable
and i get it the real bt six
um that's my stage not going into
exactly what stage is
um it's essentially where you have all
your variable that api gateway needs
the important thing is the curly bracket
proxy curly bracket
this is important because uh that would
say that when i hit it with a function
name it will go to the docker all the
way back to the docker
and it will rebuild the url saying you
know i need
this location etc etc that name of a
function so i can hit that docker with
any function that
the my our infrastructure actually
serving any function re base
in this case but it can be other ones
and this is essentially where
um this is the key over here is that
means
that i can control all my function
through the r
an api would just pass it all through
but only through the api
essentially it looks like that and you
can see it coming from
my client all the way to my proxy hit
the proxy and go back
i will finally finish this by actually
um
showing you this is a this is a a soapy
ui
i'll show you how that's actually
working practice
you can see over here i set up a post i
set up over here the api
yes i know it's east one i know there
was issues over there but that's why you
need multi
zone um but this is the name and you can
see
that i didn't name any what the name of
the function i'm naming
it in the resource and my
my proxy will take this rebase model
and rebuild it and hit and it will spawn
the the docker and get a response back
and here's my
uh post and you can see i'm providing
the latitude and the user id so let's
run this real quick
and what you can see is that we are here
we're taking that of the
this post request and i'm hitting that
and here's my recommendation i
just like that i got a recommendation
from my doctor that is based on art that
is based on the spurs metrics
um that is essentially was built
elsewhere
and now i can serve it to thousands of
thousands of people
um all at once and or go down
if i don't have to serve to anybody um
and
and at minimal minimal cost this is
really what we called in
a analytics as an api essentially it
doesn't have to be recommendation engine
any sort of prediction that you want and
you want to serve it at scale you can
use this type of id
of using a docker plumber
a application load balancer a fair get
an api gateway
all right that was a fire hose it's
really like
to uh to be a data scientist today you
need to be a full stack data scientist
and understand
the elastic load balancing and apis
there's a lot to be doing it's no longer
just
knowing how to fit a good model